categoriza cada una de las siguientes
proposiciones como verdadera falsa
vamos a ir a través de cada uno de estos
cuadros y los clasificamos como
verdadero o falso
empecemos con el primero un
acontecimiento al azar con probabilidad
de 1 es seguro qué ocurre
eso es verdadero recuerda que cuando
tenemos una probabilidad de 1 significa
que si o si va a suceder ese evento
cuando la probabilidad es igual a 0
significa que es completamente imposible
que suceda
entonces lo colocaremos en verdadero
vamos con el siguiente cuadro un
acontecimiento al azar con probabilidad
de 0.0 0001 es poco probable que ocurra
esto también es verdadero recuerda que
como lo mencionamos hace un momento si
estamos cercanos al cero es muy poco
probable que suceda así es que vamos a
colocarlo como que es poco probable que
suceda y es correcto vamos con el
siguiente cuadro un acontecimiento al
azar con probabilidad de 0.5 es seguro
que ocurra esto es falso recuerda que
solo es seguro que ocurra cuando tenemos
probabilidad de 1
aquí tenemos 0.5 es decir tenemos el 50%
de probabilidades de que suceda como el
50 por ciento de probabilidades que no
suceda así es que no podemos decir que
seguro ocurre vamos a mandarlo a falso
y finalmente tenemos este último cuadro
un acontecimiento al azar con
probabilidad de 0.99 999 es seguro que
ocurra no podemos decir que es seguro
que ocurra si es muy muy muy probable
que suceda estamos súper cercanos al 1
sin embargo aquí todavía tenemos una
diferencia que nos dice que por algún
motivo puede no suceder entonces no es
seguro que ocurra todavía tenemos una
pequeña probabilidad de que esto no
suceda si estuviésemos el número 1
entonces pudiéramos decir que seguro
ocurriría tal como lo hicimos con el
primer cuadro vamos entonces a mandarlo
a falso
y con ello tenemos nuestra respuesta
vamos a comprobarlo
y es correcta